why are you supporting him
so for me there was three key factors
the first one was someone that i could
trust to be honest and restore that
integrity back to politics and bring
back the standards in public life that
we as conservatives want to see the
second one was competence this is not
the time for someone to learn on the job
the country is facing a crisis and we
need to grip it straight away and then
thirdly he for me he's the only one
that's actually got a plan to tackle the
cost of living which is the thing that
most people are worried about and he's
going to do that by cutting taxes which
of course is the biggest pressure on
household budgets popular but boring
i don't think there's anything wrong
with boring i don't find him boring i
think actually it's about what he's
going to do for people so when i look at
him i've known him for over 10 years and
i've worked with him in
two great offices of state both in the
home office and when he was chancellor
so i've seen how
what what he's like to work with
you know when i'm sitting around the
table with him and how he deals with
issues and how he uses his judgment and
how in his heart he's motivated by doing
the right thing for the country just
looking at some of the figures he wants
40 billion pounds worth of tax cuts
how's he going to pay for it so
yesterday at his launch he published a
document setting out exactly how he is
going to pay for that and also
highlighting a number of his other
policies such as housing which i think
is really important
he has been very clear that there will
need to be
reductions in spending in every
government department and he set all
that out and i think we do need to have
that approach actually because you do
see
government departmental spending growing
over time and unless you actively grip
that and set out an objective to cut it
which i think is the right thing to do
because that is how you then can put
money back in people's pockets sure but
your safeguarding ministry is exactly
departments like yours or areas like
yours that are likely to face the acts
if that's what he's going to do i don't
think this is about an axe as you've
just put it and i know i've been through
a couple of spending rounds now as a
minister and of course every department
will ask for more money from the
chancellor that's how the process works
but i think it is it is incumbent on the
person at the top of the tree to say
well actually we're going to have this
settlement and the in the national
interest we want to be able to cut
people's taxes now so that we are
helping them to tackle the really
significant pressures on their budgets
and that's how you got to do it you've
got to show that leadership from the top
and that's what sajid will do wish you
soon as um not just specifically uh
sadie javid's campaign but he says
you're telling us fairy tales
i don't agree with that i mean obviously
i've heard that then you only have to
look at the dossier that he's published
yesterday where he has been very clear
and he has been the chancellor for a
year in the past um and so therefore
he's got the credibility to to set that
out in detail i think people need to
look at that and judge it on its own
merits people will have of course
different platforms and different offers
in this competition but it's up to
colleagues and mps to to judge that
where do they think is the most credible
approach
why was he domicile for tax purposes
when he was non-dom so he's not he's
obviously as you all know he has been um
he's someone that's had a life before
politics no you know he's not a career
politician i'm not judging that i'm just
asking where he's domiciled so i think
he's i think
he set that out yesterday he he has been
dominic he has been tax resident in
other countries
before i think he's i think he's i mean
you have to ask him
this morning i i am indeed but uh i
think he has been resident tax resident
when he was working overseas i think
singapore was one of the one he
mentioned which is pretty common there's
someone working in international finance
but i think domiciled in he was he was
tax resident there so and i think the
point really here is that while he's
been in public life he's he's he's
always been domiciled in this country
while he's been in public life i mean in
the past obviously he's had different
arrangements he's had an accountant
and he's been clear about that yesterday
he made a speech yesterday where he
addressed that question directly when
you're non-dom that means that you're
avoiding paying tax in the uk though
isn't it
well i think that would be true if
someone is a nom dom but they're living
in the uk so my understanding is and i'm
look i'm not a tax accountant right so
you know you'd have to ask a tax
accountant about this he has been he's
actually said himself that he was tax
resident in other countries but the
point is he's followed all the rules at
all times he's been absolutely
clear about that he's never been
investigated for his tax affairs he's
always come clean and been upfront and
honest about his arrangements and the
point here okay is that this is all
before he was in public life none of
this happened while he was a member of
parliament i understand how rich is he
i i you know i
i can't really answer that question you
know to be fair he earns the salary that
a member of parliament does my viewers
this morning who is struggling to feed
the kids will want to know how rich he
is they can they can judge him and all
mps have a salary that's publicly
declared it it's it's the same for any
mp it's the same for kiestarma as they
say
i don't think so i mean it's being
economical with the actuality as they
say in the business he's made an awful
lot of money previously nothing wrong
with that i'm just asking you how rich
he is he took a 99 pay cut to become an
mp
so so how can he be in touch with my
viewers so if you look at where sergeant
came from
he grew up in a very very reduced
circumstances he grew up in the
circumstances exactly like a lot of your
viewers will have his parents came to
this country he lived above the shop he
had to make his way from that background
no one helped him to do that he made his
way by his own efforts yes he's made
money later on in life due to his
success due to his talents and skills
contributing to our country and that's
what's inspired him to want to help the
party but actually if you look at where
he came from that's the key here and for
me that story about how he's managed to
get here obviously we all know his
father was a bus driver this is not a
rich upbringing as you've just suggested
no i didn't i didn't suggest that one
second i'm just asking how rich he is
and also you say that he contributed to
this country but of course he was
non-dom he wasn't contributing to this
country at the time i mean there have
been periods when he's been resident
overseas because he was working in
international business as many
others do he's contributing to this
country ever since he's been in public
life he took a tax cut as you said
because he wanted to serve the country
sorry pay cut yeah he took a pay cut
because he wanted to serve the country
and that's what he wants to do now we're
almost out of time it's busy program as
it is we really appreciate you taking
the time what are his green credentials
he he strongly believes in net zero so
that's a commitment that he will abide
by
and we all know that net zero is a way
to actually generate jobs and investment
in many parts of the country and so
sajid has been very clear that that's a
very important part of our national
strategy it's also a very important part
of leveling up you had my friend andrew
bowie on before it's really important
about uniting the country in the union
can play a really key part in the net
zero strategy because of all the
natural resources and the way that we
can create jobs in every part of the
country